nine eight seven six five four three
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsay show
where that is King in the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host thank you for joining
us open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dr John baloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today we invite you to be part
of the program and you know I'll be
answering your questions he's author of
the best-selling book a redefining
anxiety the highly popular podcast the
Dr John deloney for show where we talk
about he talks about mental health
boundaries relationships things that are
going on so you can weave those
questions into the show today if you
want he's here to help and I've always
got an opinion I'm an expert on my
opinion the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five Delaney
starting as is off in Fort Wayne Indiana
hi Delaney how are you
hi Dave
better than I deserve what's up
well my husband and I
RIS of property that our current home is
on and we are considering partialing
some of it off and building a new
property a new home on that
um and my husband and I are just having
a hard time kind of uh swallowing the
idea of spending that much on building a
new home so we were just kind of looking
for some personal advice as far as is it
appropriate for us to spend that much
money okay well there's one of two
things is telling you this either
emotion from all the years of frugality
to get to where you are and so the facts
are not that you cannot afford it
meaning you can't afford it or you're
getting ready to build too much house
and the arithmetic is telling you that
and you just need somebody say it out
loud for you okay
so how much money are you going to spend
on the house
probably about eight hundred thousand
okay how much money do you have
um we probably have around 250 000
inequities
and how much in your nest egg
um about like you
know like your 401ks your retirement
yeah
um about probably about another 250
000
okay and how old are you
I'm 32. oh okay and uh what's your
household income
about 350 000. okay
well the guideline that we use is that
can you afford to put the house on a
15-year fixed rate or the payment is no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and so the answer to 800 000 is yes you
can do that
yeah now okay here's the trick 15-year
fixed rate
and a plan to go ahead and get it paid
off with your fabulous 350 000 income
even faster than 15 years the average
millionaire in the Ramsey research that
we did 10 000 of them we studied pays
off their home in 11.2 years so I want
you to knock this thing out you have a
fabulously large shovel
your income is amazing what do y'all do
you both gonna keep working
what's wrong with your current house
uh while we have four small children so
we don't have quite enough bedrooms and
um just like they're mostly desires we
could we could definitely make it work
um but it's mostly just you know desires
for a little bit extra and that's where
we're at like you said we've been living
frequently for so long
um and now it's like okay are we okay
with with taking this next step and
spending this kind of money or should we
you know use it to benefit in other ways
now you said equity in your home is your
current home paid for
um no we have about 250 000. would you
sell that property off when you do this
good okay yeah then I I would do this
okay um now the the trick is four little
kids you can't call me up and go oh we
decided to cut our income in half
because I'm gonna stay home yeah
you gave you gave that right up when you
bought this out
yes and another we pay about forty
thousand dollars a year in child care I
know so in about three three or four
years that won't even be you know on our
budget at all so that's another area
that we'll gain more cash flow to you
well the the key part of this equation
is just your income to your payment and
you can make that work and not just make
it work it shouldn't be any trouble at
all and uh then you just keep working
your baby steps but as you as you find
money in your budget you're going to
keep working baby steps four five six
four is fifteen percent of your income
into retirement five is kids college and
six is all the other money we scrape
together from something that any other
money that comes up bonus money
increases in income whatever's all gonna
throw it at the house and this house is
gonna get paid off in sooner than 15
years and that's the pattern that you
want to be on
that that's where all the data points
lead us and so
specifically you would take that 250 put
it against this house yeah so now we're
at 550. yes and I'm looking at that
against my 325 000 of your salary that's
easy yeah that's simple math yeah 15
15-year fixed rate and where the
payments
you're usually gonna do that yeah and so
they can reach over and knock that thing
out pretty real quick it just uh it is a
little bit emotional but also really
they're taking on a big chunk of debt
because I couldn't tell early in the
call whether she like had two million
dollars set aside or something I
couldn't feel it so uh you know again
the facts will lead you to say this is
okay but the facts also say you know you
have to you have to continue the the
trick that you're on you can't change
direction on and you also have the
emotion of selling part of your 10 acre
plot and that that's your dirt right and
yeah I mean you know they're willing to
do that I think that's a that's pretty
well decided now when John deloney gets
ready to sell a piece of or that's a
problem this is like the counselor will
need counseling uh it will be hard for
me to sell dirt yeah yeah you are you
are a dirt Maniac I do like land I am
too I am too I one of my favorite places
on the planet is my big old farm and
ain't nothing on it but some grass and
rabbits I remember going out to it the
first time bunch of spent shell casings
that's I went out there and where's the
oh no this is
and I thought oh this is a happy place
man there's nothing else here it's
incredible nothing else here just a big
old piece of dirt and somebody needs to
hold the rest of the earth together and
that piece of dirt does it so that's why
I'm here that's my uh my calling you
know I'd have a hard time parceling but
again everybody does their thing but uh
you taught me this
um when you start playing with bigger
shovels and you start playing with
bigger zeros and it really leaning to
those ratios is important yeah it is a
little bit like you know your trauma
formula facts are your friends yeah yeah
okay what's really going on not what's
the emotion right you know and what's
really going on is you do it you do the
math and you know you look at a
projection on that and you look at the
facts and then you say okay why am I
scared yeah why am I ashamed why then do
I have these negative feelings when all
the math indicates I shouldn't do you
still if I go look at a new truck I
still have a number from the first time
I looked at a truck back in 97 and I
look at new trucks now and I sound like
a grandfather like what do they do you
know what I mean because of my head it
should be 17 grand if you believe they
charge them for a pickup that's exactly
right now you can it just stays here
your grandfather coming out of your own
mouth I love it you're a great
grandfather my great granddaddy yeah
with these prices
my tire
one wheel that's all I can afford one
wheel uphill both ways in the snow
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to Pure Talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month to get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data with no
contract the Irish family saves over
seventy dollars a month by switching to
Pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code Ramsay to save 50
off your first month Pure Talk simply
smarter Wireless
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
debt-free screams they're fun a lot of
times there's hardly a dry eye in the
places these folks tell their stories
but none tug at your heart like the ones
we get where a mom or dad has passed
away and now their family's debt free
because they took care of business and
they had term life insurance in place
before
their spouse passed away
now that would make you cry for sure
and that's what it looks like when you
have your act together your family is
taken care of in the good times and in
the bad
insurance is your defense investing is
your offense
you got to play both
you're going to win
and it's why it's not okay to put it off
you got to get term life insurance in
place you need to do it right now
and we've made finding a policy really
easy for you with our term life
calculator you can answer a few
questions and give us a snapshot of your
life and our free calculator will show
you how much coverage you really need
which ends up being about 10 to 12 times
your annual income on each of you and
how long you need to keep the insurance
in place and all this takes less than
five minutes and it's completely free
and you find the best policy compare
rates with Xander our trusted partner
and they'll shop a dozen plus top
insurance companies to find the best
deal for you it's easy to get your
results completely free text term life
to 33 789 term life
233-789 and find the best policy for you
in a couple hours John deloney my
co-host Dr John deloney and I are going
to be doing an entree leadership theme
hour
and if you would like to participate in
that meaning you have business questions
can be anything about business that you
want to talk about people issues
marketing issues money issues ideas
whatever it is you're struggling with or
got questions about in business we're
going to take business as particularly
small business question uh that hour and
if you want to participate in that email
right now and Kelly will make you a part
of that hour and just email Dave on air
at
ramsesolutions.com Dave on air
ramseysolutions.com and uh we'll get you
on the entree leadership theme hour
coming up in a couple hours
so jump on there and make sure you do
that
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Albert is in
Austin Texas hey Albert how are you
I'm doing good how about you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
so basically I have about 140 000 in
student loan debt between me and my wife
we make about 140 Grand a year and we
basically are in a position where we can
either make monthly payments of fourteen
hundred dollars a month and pay off all
our debt in 10 years or we can enter
into a repayment plan
um put about the maximum into our 401ks
and essentially pay zero dollars for the
first five years and then after 20 years
potentially get everything forgiven so
I'm trying to see whether we should just
start to pay it off completely or
whether the repayment plan could have
some benefits that you know allows the
save money and invest earlier because
you know compound interest
um
what's your degree in
so I have a master's in finance and my
wife she has a Bachelor's of Science in
nursing
I saw that one coming
um okay Albert
um I don't know what uh the Greek word
for irony is but I think it's Finance
degree
oh in 140 000 well done man you're a
smart kid aren't you
well it most of it was actually for me
so before I got my Master's Degree we
had about 70 grand and then that program
cost about an extra 70 000 but it did
increase my um income by about 30
percent so I saw it as worth it so you
increase your debt load by 100 and your
salary by
30. yeah but the the amount of time it
would take to you know kind of get that
30 increase in my regular career which
was I did a bachelor's in accounting
which took me about five years so I
saved five years of time trying to move
up the ladder by just going to school
one year
okay I I have a degree in finance as
well and people that are wired like me
and you uh have a
10 well you've ever you've always heard
that your greatest strength is your
greatest weakness right Albert
yeah and my I have a couple of
Tendencies because of my
um
uncanny ability with math I'm very good
with math
and you are too I can tell because
everything that you've talked about
since you got on the phone is all about
mathematical analysis
and so the uh you and John's right
you're obviously a very bright guy those
things are actually going to work
against you in this conversation though
um and because they've worked against me
in my past and so being the old older
nerd of the two of us in this
conversation
um I made the mistake of thinking that I
could measure all issues like Risk
and strain
and
relationship messes with a math formula
and you can't
uh and so for instance in the formula
that you just used to justify your
master's degree you did not have
anything in that math formula for the
extra risk you took on with a seventy
thousand dollar extra weight
all you did was just look at a simple
Roi and so you left life variables out
of your formula called risk and thereby
would have neutralized some of your
mathematical conclusions but you learned
that after risk knocks your freaking
teeth out a couple of times and then you
go okay the math formula missed that and
that's what happened to me so and has
more than once and so we need to do the
best we can do with a mathematical
analysis but you what I'm going to urge
you to do is to realize earlier rather
than later because it hurt me I brought
pain into my life that math does not
measure Common Sense math does not
measure risk very often there's a few
places you can actually use a beta in an
inverted formula and you know what I'm
talking about on an investment Albert
but but there's very few times that
people actually plug risk into these
equations
which makes your which makes our math
naive
it's it's um it's uh emotionally
immature
does that make any sense and so all of
all of that to say no
do not stay in debt 20 years and try to
screw around and get rich with your 401k
while you do three versions of a
two-step twirl around hoping some
political thing is going to come along
and bail your butt out of this
ridiculous hole you dug yourself into no
you take your hundred and forty thousand
dollar income and you punch this mess
you made in the mouth and you get rid of
the student loan as fast as you can
because all the data that we have on
millionaires says that none of them not
a single one and we studied ten thousand
of them and this is statistically
significant not a single one said I'm
going to keep my student loan around as
long as I can and dance with it so that
I can invest in my 401k and it will
offset and I understand mathematically
how you got there but dude naive doesn't
even touch this conversation please
set the pencil down
and go and just pay off your student
loan get visceral emotional about it and
get rid of the mess quit walking around
proud about the fact you've got it it's
a it's a mess now go fix it here's what
it looks like in real life you got a
wife it's a nurse Albert you have a
finance job as Dave said there's any
sort of Correction in the market and
they call you in because you're new and
you're young and you're gone
and suddenly your five-year acceleration
turns into a seven year deceleration
that's number one right so and you're
gonna say that never happened to me I
got a graduate degree cool live in that
world step two is your wife who's a
nurse after year seven says I cannot do
this anymore the secondary trauma is
wearing me out or you have a kid and you
end up with twins and she says I want to
stay home or or one of them has needs
you are yeah one of them's got special
you are hedging a 10-year bet and I
don't know if you know anything about
the last 10 years I'm not betting
nothing except the the
the turtle's gonna win every single time
and I'm gonna take the the small step
and the smart step this is not a math
problem it's a psychology and it's
almost spiritual trick life with a mass
formula yeah you're gonna get your face
smacked off don't do it pay it off three
years man three years three years you
need to be debt free in three years and
then move on with your life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jordan and Andrea are
on the line in Canada I see on my screen
you guys are debt free congratulations
hi thank you we are way to go how much
have you paid off we have paid off 129
575 in 26 months and your range of
income during that time we started at
sixty thousand and we are at about 135
000 now
60 to 135 so uh did like somebody get a
job that didn't have one how do you
double your income in two years yes we
were on a single income while my husband
went 1500 kilometers away to school I
I guess on one income and then he
can crushing it ever since love it got a
new job what's his degree in
in what
what's a field of direct funeral
director funeral oh
I thought I thought what field is here
and what in funerals yes that would be
that would be the field yes that's right
yeah okay and what do you do
I'm a nurse awesome wow and what was the
debt the 130 000.
pension buyback from maternity leave we
had financed a water system for our
house student loans
uh credit cards
line of credits you guys were like
normal totally normal wow we're happy to
be weird now what was the wake-up call
that got you so intense to knock this
out so quickly
uh for me Jordan was away at school and
he had about three weeks left in school
and we had burned through all of our
savings
and uh
work and he only had three weeks left
um
and
that was just our absolute rock bottom
and I was so blessed to have
um
a friend named Sarah on Instagram who
um she took the time to sit down with me
and do a FaceTime call and teach me how
to budget and use the every dollar
app and then I got started we read
Financial Peace and Total Money Makeover
and we never looked back
and you made it through the three weeks
alive huh yeah he he almost didn't but
he did wow
wow so earlier today we took a call from
somebody who is interested in playing a
finance game with their about a very
similar debt number two years for about
a decade to 20 years
on the other end of other side of having
this all paid off put into words what it
feels like to who not owe anybody
anything
we're leaving
yeah it's um you know all the money that
we have is is our money
and we can do whatever we want with it
and
um
you know it's a huge weight off our
shoulders it's just it's so hard to put
into words
um the type of emotional emotions and
feelings that we have
um but that would be the
the best that we could put into words is
it's just absolutely
relief for our family the horrible part
of your story is also the most beautiful
part of your story is when you
completely emotionally hit the wall
at that three-week Mark and three weeks
from him coming home and
uh
uh what that does is you will never go
back never
because of that feeling in your chest
versus now there's not an elephant
standing on your chest anymore
now we can move forward it would have
been nicer to hop in our teens when we
could have learned and moved forward a
lot quicker but no regrets um just so
blessed and so thankful that we were
able to come across you and your team
it's just been unbelievable 130 000 paid
off in 26 months
people are listening going okay
what did they do
what do you do what's the key
what's the key for you
yeah sticking with it uh it was the
hardest but most gratifying process
um the hardest part for us was getting
started like with anything else getting
started educating ourselves and getting
that written budget down it was a
whirlwind but it was worth every
stressor every
um
you know every transaction we made
putting that in that Trend that app I
still do that daily I was just doing
that before this call
um not a day goes by that we don't track
our budget it's an absolute must amen
amen Jordan what about your current line
of work where you're a director
what's that sorry what about that line
your new line of work puts a little bit
of urgency into the everyday
yeah I mean it's it's definitely
different than what I'm used to but it
was a welcome change and
along with new financial
responsibilities it really
molded together nicely but you get you
get a ringside seat into knowing at the
end of the day where this all ends right
you you're a funeral director and so the
folks I know in that in that world tend
to have
a little bit better grasp of the
importance of every moment of every day
of the relational costs right yeah
exactly I mean we're all going to end up
in the same place so
yeah yeah way to go you guys are studs
man you guys are amazing thank you yeah
so I suspect this second part of your
sentence a while ago on Andrea is
um
the very hard to get started but then
every month and every debt that went
away it got easier and easier and easier
to wear it the whole thing like was on a
curve to where it went from very hard to
ridiculously in a Zone yeah absolutely
and you know now it's become a hobby
day every transaction and now it's it's
just life and it's amazing yeah it's
part of the who's going to pick up the
kids and where's the money yeah
absolutely and where does it go yep
that's it tell me where it went that's
what I want to know I love it you guys
are amazing well we've got a copy of uh
the Legacy Journey for you because
that's for sure you've changed your
legacy and that's the next chapter in
your story you're going to be off to the
land of millionaire now and and Beyond
and uh infinity and beyond it's the Buzz
Lightyear of Finance so yeah you're on
your way and uh also a copy of The Total
Money Makeover for you to give to
someone like the friend uh gave you her
time and love off of Instagram to step
onto every dollar budgeting app and help
you get going on that I'm very well done
so great job
thank you so much Jordan and Andrea from
Canada 130 000 paid off in 26 months
making 60 to 135. count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream ready three two
one yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I love it wow you couldn't have lined
those numbers up Dave between that and
the last call oh yeah or a few calls ago
right the almost the almost same answer
and the exact same amount of dad and his
wife was a nurse and she I mean it lines
up so you've got one person trying to
finagle the math between 10 and two
decades now 10 years or two decades or
somebody who had that call right it's
just it's a good warning for all of us
that are math nerds that are really good
with math is a is a wonderful blessing
but it causes you to try to hide the pee
under the shell and uh and think you can
and and we have a little bit of
arrogance in our approach to it that we
think we can do it because the math
works with the calculator I can I can I
mean I I you you know the regular math
guy can't do that but I think I can hide
this P but the stinking peas under one
of those shells that's a problem it you
know it's just a street game at the end
of the day so yeah it's tough tough this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
in the third hour we're going to be
talking to business owners and leaders
for an entree leadership theme hour if
you have a business question go ahead
and email Kelly right now and she will
put you into that hour
oh you can just call call
okay just call in now if you can get
through the lines are full but anyway if
you get in she'll get you set up for
that third hour if you've got a business
question the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five a
couple of other show notes and things
that are going on we're continuing to do
shows about America's what is what one
guy calls America's greatest
legalized fraud
time shares
and uh yesterday I took calls for an
hour from people the stories
are just
they're they're humorous because they're
so freaking ridiculous give me one like
a Saturday Night Live skit
so um if you're a timeshare owner or a
time a former timeshare owner and you'd
like to take this survey we're doing
some research on the industry text
timeshare to 33 789 timeshare to
33789
and if you want to participate in our
next timeshare show meaning you want to
tell your story about your interaction
with the timeshare business let 20
million plus people hear your story we'd
love to have you do that you can again
use the email Dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com put timeshare on the
subject line put a little bit about
what's going on and your phone number
and Kelly o'calling setting up we don't
tell you what to say but we need to get
you scheduled for that particular hour
so tell me to tell me what you heard
tell me one so the funniest one was the
guy who
uh I think the timeshare was in in the
Virginia area if I remember right and uh
the guy came running in to do the
presentation room full of people
and late and jumped up on stage and goes
I don't even know what I'm doing uh the
guy they're supposed to do this isn't
here and so I'm gonna be your guy which
is a complete [ __ ] oh that's part of
the gift it's a part of a bit okay and
while he's and he's talking about how if
you uh if you love your family
you will bring them on vacation because
families that do vacations you know they
stick together and it's it's a loving
act and if the only people who don't
take their family on vacations just
don't love their families and while he's
saying this the his phone rings and he
answers the phone while he's on stage
and it's his mother who's getting chemo
and she's calling in
no way not his mom at all just another
bit and so you know it's just like it's
like a Saturday Night Live skit this is
like something you would like Chris
Farley How does it go back down by the
river you know I'm at work
how does what work so like so I I you
know I'm writing a book right now you
looked at an early part of it and
there's a true story in there and you
say the way that true story lines up
metaphorically is almost too good to be
true and so you and I are reading this
like I experienced this we're reading it
but we both see it coming 100 miles away
how does somebody in an audience not
realize man well the guy calling he was
like he said my wife and I are at the
back laughing okay rolling our eyes but
he said there are people buying every
bit of it you know they're like a bass
on the hook baby I mean anything that's
shiny you go for it right and so wow
yeah it's um the old uh uh was it WC
Fields or Barnum one PT Barnum says
sucker's born every minute that's right
you know I think let me show you a
little swamp land in Florida here baby
and I guess you've got modernization in
Florida is called uh timeshare that's
what it is that's what it's called
and why do you go the one that I can't
figure out anybody of any level of
naivete why you actually go
and spend five hours with these slimy
people
trying and think you're going to get out
of there with your skin intact me and my
closest friends after about two and a
half hours were like hey you know that's
enough of you like yeah I can't do five
hours and you know and I had a granola
bar and an orange juice and my blood
sugar is getting low I'm getting ready
to kill something here and it may be you
but yeah it's like yeah
yeah but it people do it they do
anything for a free
something and that's what it is I'll
give you a free pass to the zoo if
you're going the tiger Cajun pet the
tiger for three hours so one of the
things and pray you don't get eaten
right but you get to go to the zoo if
you live through it I used to do when I
talked to parents um of new students
coming into college I would say hey and
your kids get free counseling and by
free I mean you give me 120 Grand and
they can have 12 free sessions a year
and uh so if you give me a hundred
thousand bucks you can come to my house
and use my laundry machines for free
laundry if you want so if you are
thinking about a timeshare how about
this
um you give me a quarter of your
annualized investment and I'll let you
come stay at my house for a few weekends
a year how about that that's a good
trade I'm in I'm in careful somebody
will even I know they will I guarantee
you they will Chris is in Los Angeles
hey Chris how are you
I'm doing great how are you guys good
how can we help
awesome so I'm single I'm in my late 30s
I'm in baby steps four through six
um I've not been contributing to my 401k
for the past 14 months because I was out
of work and just piling up cash from
unemployment and Severance
um fast forward use a bunch of Ken
Coleman's resources for resumes
interviews landed a new job and so I've
restarted my 401K Roth contributions now
that I'm working again the question is
awesome yeah thank you thank you very
much can cans Ken's resources are
awesome if you're looking for a job
everyone should check that out thank you
um so my question is should I increase
my contribution amount above the
recommended 15
to help make up for the 14-month gap or
just keep it at 15 and just focus on the
road ahead that's a great question
well
um neither neither answer is in the dumb
column okay because in either case
you're going to be in great shape right
yeah so uh the way I look at it is this
um you did exactly what you were
supposed to do
you piled up cash and stopped your baby
steps to survive the storm and now we're
pushing play again which is 15 of your
income towards retirement and taking
care of kids college if that's
applicable and paying off the house
maybe step six do you owe money on your
house
uh I'm renting right now
the pile of money might be your down
payment fund then and it could it can
sit there for a little while until
you're ready to buy and you know you
don't have to buy it a day but that's
until when you're ready to buy it's
still sitting there so here's the thing
um
if we unders you need to if you
understand this idea it'll tell you it
doesn't matter
which one you do but it doesn't matter
if you don't do an additional I wouldn't
do an additional I just keep it at 15.
here's why
you're not going to be in baby steps
four five six for the rest of your life
you're only going to be in four five and
six until the house is bought and paid
off at which point you will escalate
you will no longer be doing baby step
four or 15 you're going to max out all
retirement at that point
uh to keep the government's hands off of
it and you're going to increase your
investing because you're going to be in
maybe step seven you'll increase your
generosity you'll increase your
investing uh because that's what baby
step seven is build wealth and give and
so
um uh
so there's a better than half of your
remaining working years will not include
a house payment and you will be doing
much more than 15 percent so it doesn't
really matter if you go to 20 now
because you're still going to be over
there in that baby step seven land
investing way more than 15 percent in
the back half of this story to where
you're going to be just fine so I
wouldn't I would just stay at 15 and I'd
let that money you piled up I would hold
it aside for a down payment above your
emergency fund uh and then just keep
moving right along and then when you buy
the house your next goals get the house
paid off and when you do that trip maybe
step seven and then the 15 no longer
applies I love that question it's a
really good thoughtful thing but um
the thing that that we all have a
tendency to do
um with the baby steps or anything else
is we say okay if I invest 15 of my
income for 30 years
well you're really not going to do that
you're gonna invest 15 until you're done
because your income is going to change
right so you and we don't know what but
it's most of the time most people's life
it's going to go up okay uh it may go
down then go up but it's it's gonna oh
the average the trend line is going to
be upward so we don't know exactly how
to project that so if you run your
numbers at 15 only on only today's
income you're more than okay there but
guess what it's all upside from that
that's right because you're an a when
you get on the back side you're not
gonna be doing 15 anymore I love it B
your income's going to go up so it just
doesn't work out in linear fashion
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books our thanks to John deloney
my co-host James Childs our producer and
Kelly Daniel our associate producer
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of Ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
Ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the Ramsay
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsey show
where net is dumb cash is king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm Dave Ramsey your host thank
you for joining us Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
he is the host of the Dr John Dr John
deloney show where he answers questions
about mental health relationships
boundaries
anxiety and other things that are going
on the show is uh it's a wonderful
success and if you want to participate
in his show you can email him at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com with a question for
that show or leave a voicemail and Kelly
and the team will get back to you they
produce that show the number is
844-693-3291 but he's here today if you
want to talk to him and the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five Courtney is with
us in Battle Creek Michigan hi Courtney
how are you
hi I'm I'm well how are you better than
I deserve what's up
so I'm a human medicine pa
um I've been working in private practice
and I am a little leadership role right
now but could foresee possibly an
opportunity to buy into the practice
maybe within the next five years or so
so I guess I'm just hoping for some
advice on potentially how to save up to
by end of the practice and also kind of
what to consider financially and
personally making that big of a decision
um
well uh this situation and a law firm
are the two times that I have seen
what is effectively a partnership work
uh most of the time in business
Partnerships don't work uh we always
with when we're dealing with entree
leadership team in business setting we
just tell them the ownership won't sales
or partnership so but you do have even
though they uh the vast majority of
these medical Partnerships do work uh
they work because you've got very very
clear clearly delineated rights and
responsibilities and processes for death
disability uh whatever default uh
whatever happens or any of the Deeds
that happen you guys they probably have
very good agreement structure and that's
what helps them to survive so but you do
want to learn about all of that so kind
of think about what are the worst case
scenarios on everything and how is that
addressed uh when a partner dies that's
bought in what happens when they go
through a divorce what happens when they
go uh when they don't pay or do their
part when they're no longer interested
in showing up for work disinterest so
disinterest divorce disability they lose
the ability to come to work what happens
to their shares your shares uh how do
you get paid or not get paid what is
your requirement to participate and so
it's it is a bunch of D's it's divorce
death disability disinterest default
drug use you know all these what are all
the stuff people tricks people can do
dummy every once in a while a partner
just is a dumb one
okay I'm just trying to think of a good
deal to jump in here
feel free John so uh but that you know
that that but my guess is when you do
investigate that and understand that
you're probably going to find it's
probably well thought out where in most
two guys opening a heat and air store a
heating air company it's never thought
out and so that's where the disasters
all come from but these but you guys are
in a world that's very well developed in
that area so that's thing one thing two
is the way you save up is you say this
is so important I'm going to save up I
mean I'm gonna I'm gonna treat this like
I'm paying off my house I'm gonna pile
up cash so fast and we're gonna live on
nothing so that when this opportunity
comes I can write the check because I'm
not going into debt to do it
yeah absolutely not
so um and and then the the last thing is
that um
it is what the voting and governance
structure is because you're going to be
uh uh a minority shareholder you're not
going to have the ability to vote by
yourself and tell everybody what to do
because you don't have 51 percent
and
how the voting process or the governing
process works here because you do not
have the ability to just stop some you
don't have a trump card you don't have a
you can't just stop bad things from
happening and they're happening where
you just paid X number of hundreds of
thousands of dollars to become a part of
this and you have no control
um so that's the yeah it's very
emotionally
uh strenuous to be a minority
shareholder because
you got really your life savings
invested in something you can't control
and that that that's the dangerous part
and that's why I tell people not to do
it uh except in these situations
I have seen you know I don't know what
the percentages are but the vast
majority are successful so uh versus
other types of Partnerships so I'm not
going to tell you not to do it and where
I in your shoes I probably would do it
but with cash and I just need to
understand
uh the secret to happiness is uh Lowered
Expectations I need to understand what
happens in all the worst case scenarios
including me getting out voted on
something because they want to take a
political stance uh with this that I'm
perpendicular to uh with our
whatever procedure internally we want to
make a public statement that's
perpendicular to my belief system and
now I'm part of it because I'm an owner
in this and I can't keep it from
happening so those are the kinds of
things you've got to kind of address and
and
you know if they're not written parts of
the documents at least set your own
expectations on them because when it
turns sideways you know I took this risk
on is there any rule of thumb for
pricing out
a buy-in like this
you know it's some Net Present Value it
is it's it's an noi thing in net
operating income so the income of the
practice after everybody's been paid is
the what the shareholders divvy up and
so what are you getting on average if
you own one-fifth of the practice I'm
gonna it's five hundred thousand dollars
I'm gonna get a hundred thousand dollars
okay so what am I going to pay for that
usually not more than three or four
hundred thousand so you can look out
just three to five years now you're
you're gonna break even in three years
probably and a lot of them break even
faster than that okay because there's a
a sense that they want to keep her
because she's become such an integral
part of the practice and so they're
letting her Buy in and sometimes
fifty percent of what a stranger would
buy in okay because it's you want those
Partners all knit together because it's
golden handcuffs then yeah then she
can't just she can't just walk away
which it can but it'll be it'd be
ludicrous okay financially it becomes
golden handcuffs so if for that reason
they're usually priced very good for the
buyer gotcha very good usually a very
cool situation to be in yeah it's uh it
is again it's it's a an anomaly in
business uh that the medical
Partnerships but it's important you just
said that you don't pay off the front
end line you pay off
what has trickled through down yeah to
the to the shareholder to the owners
yeah absolutely I mean that's the way
all Partners gets from profit but you
know so that's that's where we are Dr
John deloney Ramsey personalities my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey
[Music]
hey folks I got a great option to help
you pay for your education the Army
National Guard the Army National Guard
believes you are the next greatest
Generation because you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed that's why they offer
benefits like tuition assistance Career
Training and a paycheck to help you
avoid debt no matter what your goals are
the Army National Guard can help you get
there visit nationalguard.com to find
out more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're struggling to
keep up with payments you know what it's
like to be so scared and overwhelmed you
can't think straight you don't have to
live like that anymore
when you pay off your debt as fast as
possible you will never have that kind
of stress again and you'll have control
of your most powerful wealth building
tool your income because you're not
giving it to everyone else you know
where you do this Financial Peace
University
almost 10 million people have been
through this class guys
and they learned how to pay off debt
they learned how to work together if
they're married take control of their
money start investing
you know it's a it is a proven thing you
can stream all nine lessons right now or
you can get some extra support by going
through the class with other people and
and you know like live and in person
remember when we did that and the only
way to get Financial Peace University of
course is your it's part of your Ramsay
Plus Membership
and of course your every dollar premium
is a part of your Ramsay Plus Membership
so that's the world's best budgeting app
so we're going to give you all the tools
and the lessons and everything but
Financial Peace University gets you
there you can get rid of the debt that's
holding you back you can learn how to
invest learn how to be outrageously
generous with a free trial for Financial
Peace University at Ramsay plus now free
trial or Ramsay plus text trial to 33
789 text trial two three three seven
eight nine our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer anywhere of custom window
coverings this is an incredible company
great Texas company started out of a
guy's garage Jay is a friend of mine he
built the company up and it it still
runs with his DNA good people free
samples free shipping new promos they
run all the time blinds.com use the
promo code Ramsay to get the best deal
so today's question comes from Victoria
in Texas
Victoria writes my fiance will finish
his medical residency this year his 150
000 in student loans nine grand in
credit card debt and no emergency fund
when we first met he always said that
the best investment you could make is
paying off your debt but his priorities
have now changed he makes uh oh he makes
minimum payments on the credit card
deferred the student loans and allocates
the rest of his money drumroll please to
cryptocurrency I have a little throw up
in my mouth
it is crazy I promise he promises that
he'll start paying off debt as soon as
his residency ends but it worries me
that he prefers to invest in something
that's risky rather than paying off his
debt should I be concerned about this
new obsession or should I trust that he
will eventually make his debt a priority
man so anytime somebody says hey this is
a important thing for me and you go
great and then they change it on you and
they do something different and then
they say hey but next time but next time
you can trust me and then that changes
again
yes you should be concerned about the
Integrity of the person that you're
walking alongside
yes you should be concerned I think
I absolutely do actually in fact the
more I think about this the more
frustrating this gets
because you've got a scared fiance here
and you've got somebody who has some
wisdom in one area of life I think you
guys getting this straightened out prior
to marriage is a deal breaker I agree
um and that's sitting down with your
pre-marriage counselor and coming to
terms with a uh you're no longer aligned
on how money is handled and B uh he's
changed his mind I'll tell you what I
think has happened
and
a good spanking in the marriage
counselor's office will fix it because
he's going to get to try to choose
between you and crypto
um if you're my daughter and
um so not because I hate crypto but
because of this whole the way he's doing
this in his whole process so my
experience of coaching is uh people with
their finances
there are more broke doctors
medical doctors than any other thing I
run into I mean we see all the broke
athletes are broke music people that
make all their money and then they lose
it all but broke doctors hide it behind
a BMW with a lease payment and so people
don't realize how bad their finances are
and when I've sat down with them over
the years they're unbelievably suck at
how they handle their money that's about
to say you get there's an arrogance
built in right that's exactly why I can
take a heart out so surely I know surely
I can do cryptocurrency right and so
what I smell is a young medical student
who took his class on I am now God I'm a
doctor and I know everything and so he
got he got downloaded The Arrogant
download and uh
that a good spanking in the therapist's
office will fix that or a good thinking
in the market we'll fix it yeah but I
don't want him I don't want to be
attached to him taking her down when she
you know the you don't want to go down
with a drowning guy here because he
because but here's the thing it's not
what he's doing but why he's doing it
that's the deal breaker because if I'm
right if he is doing if he changed from
his common sense when he was humble to
now I'm arrogant and so I can play
things that other people can't play and
I will come out which every time you
play in a high risk thing that's that's
involved right you have to think you've
got the edge on something that no one
else does I've got the ticket on this
horse so I can bet the farm at this
horse race you know and I've got an edge
and and because and arrogance is what
this is It's pride pride comes right
before the fall so the the
that's what's the deal breaker because
when it's not crypto it's going to be
something else it's going to be another
thing and he's going to go buy into a
pizza chain and that's going to go broke
and then he's going to go buy fried
pickles and then he's going to do
because he's always because he's so
freaking smart
that is a deal breaker right because
you're going to live a life of
bull crap sucky decisions to bull crap
sucky decisions to bullcrap sucky
decisions it's just going to be one
after another until this pride is broken
I know this guy because I was him as was
I that's right I keep saying Victoria I
am this guy right I know a lot of stuff
about a really small this is how Dave
Ramsey went broke because I am
inordinately good with math I can see
things I can see a deal I can feel math
when it's on a piece of paper I I I'm
not good at a lot of stuff but so I
could walk into a real estate deal and
ding ding ding ding and I can tell you
today 35 years later exactly what I pay
for that property what we spent on it
and what I made on it they just those
numbers are stored I can't get them out
of my head I see them they're on a
chalkboard in my mind you know and so
because I thought I was so such all that
uh that I went and built a dadgum house
of cards and it came crashing down on
guess what my wife and my kids head so I
often find when I'm in one of these
arrogant modes or when I'm with folks
like like this and I've spent a lot of
times behind closed doors of medical
folks
they can feel or sense that deal
they can't feel or sense the person they
love sitting next to them in the
driver's seat suddenly feeling like they
just their their Lifeline just got yep
it got got cut right yep and yeah I'm
with you the scary thing about this
Victoria is this is a pattern that I've
seen over and over and over and over so
if he can become one of the smartest
doctors that is humble and realizes he's
good at medicine and sucks at money
and needs to do basic Grandma common
sense with money if he can revisit that
line line that's an indication he has
become humble and rather than prideful
and that is marriage material yeah but
it's not the detail of cryptocurrency
versus paying off your student loans
that's not the detail that's not the
deal breaker it's the why under it that
is a reason not to marry this guy
absolutely until you get this fixed and
so that that's because you're gonna
you're signing up for a lifetime a
heartache yeah and crap falling down
around your head because I man I tell
you the number of doctors who've earned
four fortunes and only have one yeah um
with three wives too right yeah yeah and
two husbands and you we when we do this
stuff when we're arrogant and we we drag
our families through the same thing yeah
and they get to go along for the ride
and uh you know I say you know I used to
say well you know Sharon was really
afraid when we were going through all
this and she would go no
the word is terrified not because of the
situation but because you kept doing it
that's right terrified
terrified my wife
Victoria
you're terrified I can see it in on the
page here and you should be
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
in Denver Lane and Kaylee are with us
hey guys how are you
well I guess if I pick up the phone then
I could talk to him there we go hey
we're doing great how are you better
than I deserve man I see on my screen
you're debt free congratulations how
much did you pay off
we paid off fifty seven thousand dollars
all right and how long congratulations
you took 26 months good for you and your
range of income during that time time uh
we started at a hundred and five
thousand and currently we're at just
over 135 000. good for you
and uh what kind of debt was this
uh so we had two cars uh personal loan
one really big credit card and uh cell
phones okay cool and what do you guys do
for a living
so I am a plumber and Kaylee is a
stay-at-home mom and does some Property
Management on the side all right very
good yes so how long you guys been
married
we've been married 12 wonderful years
wonderful so what happened two years ago
that was the wake-up call 26 months ago
yeah you know we had taken Financial
Peace shortly before two years ago and
it was really great class and we were
like yes we could do that but we just
couldn't figure it out we would go to
financial peace and we'd go out to eat
after and because we were like we're so
broke so clearly that's what we should
do go out to eat right well then just a
couple months later we were taking
Financial Peace and I went to file our
tax returns and I we pull out all the
W-2s and I say we make six figures did
you know that Elaine's like I didn't
know that but why are we so broke if we
make six figures so that was really what
kind of kicked us into gear filing those
tax returns and seeing we were making
way too much money to be so broke a
healthy level of disgust
yeah absolutely good for you now they
just popped your uh family's picture up
on the YouTube screen right here and I
saw it in the lobby how many kids have
you got
we have eight children and we have a
ninth on the way in October all right
congratulations way to go so you fed
eight baby birds while you're doing this
yes we did WOW because sometimes I hear
people say on social media well now you
know you can't do that Dave Ramsey stuff
if you have a big family it's true it's
true I actually admin a Catholic large
family group on Facebook and every time
someone would talk about finances I
would hear a lot of people say Dave
Ramsey never works or you tear the other
half say the only thing that works is
Dave Ramsey and then all of a sudden all
these large families started breaking
off into these space group book groups
and saying you know Dave Ramsey for
large families because really it is the
only thing that works yeah well I've
heard the opposite too so yeah that's
interesting all right yeah it's the only
thing that works period not Dave Ramsey
but these Common Sense principles is not
me but the uh and the only thing that
works is when you actually work it's you
guys are the heroes I'm so proud of you
how's it feel to be free
yeah it feels amazing honestly um for
the first time in our life where you
know not struggling to pay bills or
living paycheck to paycheck and
for myself
um being you know a dad of eight and a
husband of a wonderful wife
um
it's
for me it's just exhilarating to be
debt-free like it's
it's it's so much weight lifted off my
shoulders yeah um yeah it's just been
amazing so what does sacrifice look like
in a large family because it looks like
you did about two thousand dollars a
month average through that 26 months
um and and meanwhile feeding eight eight
point three kids
yeah it was really a lot of Lane using
his trade and really so many people of
our friends and family who referred Lane
and trusted him and really just sang
whoever needs a sink or a toilet or a
remodel or whatever needed to be done
you know Lane that was just really
really great about going to work and
then going to side job after side job
and going to work and and you know his
his work was really fantastic about
um when all the lockdown and
all of the all of the like quarantine
things came in their business actually
picked up a lot of they service a lot of
restaurants and so we were worried we
thought oh restaurants we are dead in
the water but there were a ton of
restaurants who said hey all those big
jobs that we never want to shut down our
restaurant for let's do those and so
they he was able to stay really busy and
truly I mean every one of our friends
and and family who hired Lane and
believed in him and referred him to
their friends they supported this
journey even if they didn't know it
because they supported the family
instead of a business and that was huge
for us he got so many referrals
how did the kids participate in this
they were you know they they listened to
a lot of podcasts in the car
um not willingly sometimes you know they
get a lot of complaints sometimes but um
you know they you know staying home a
lot eating at home was a big thing you
know like you said we like to eat out
and so eating at home was a huge change
for them so they uh they were very
gracious about it though it was very you
know they they helped cook so that we
did when we were exhausted they stepped
up and helped cook so that we didn't
order food or go somewhere or yeah they
were phenomenal
and I'm just thinking of all of the
generational shift that just happened
not only with the debt profile right but
now you've got a dad who works a hard
manual job with demanding people who's
going to come home a little less
stressed and you've got a marriage
that's you know a little over 10 years
old with basically y'all are about a a
kid a year right that's a good turnover
right and um there's going to be a
little less stress and over time that
it's going to magnify now you got kids
who know how to cook and work together
and do fun things and enjoy each other's
company and you're talking about
transforming a tree with a lot of roots
on it right
very cool it's not just paying off debt
good for you guys very cool absolutely
thank you one thing you know about most
large families it's not 100 true but
more so than small families is the kids
are not entitled because it's not an
option
it's very true yes it's something as
simple as we come out here to take
pictures at the break uh if if there's
one or two sometimes the kids are
running wild but if there's like four or
five it's like with the military walk
right up there
assume the position for the picture boom
and they line up right because hands
will come from everywhere and hit you
right
straighten up yeah so I'm sure they got
on board I'm sure they did because they
you have to get on board just to stay
seen in a house like this this is
awesome absolutely I'm so proud you guys
are so impressive what a neat family
what a great story well done well thank
you guys for going out there and winning
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
uh sting to a budget is a it's huge yeah
the budget's key yes
um I would say Learning To Suffer Well
as well
yeah Lane was so great about suffering
well the kids really got to see him work
really hard and never complain and I was
not always had such a good attitude as
Lane did and I could just tell I was
like even I'm annoying myself even stop
complaining it's not doing any good
um but the kids will really tell you
that their their dad suffers really well
he works really hard and he's just the
last person to ever complain or or say
anything negative he just always keeps
us all going and made his year yeah
that's awesome to hear a wife say that
about her husband that's so cool well
done it's interesting you know our 13
year old daughter she was really
instrumental she would color in all of
the charts and every time we'd get paid
where are we at what are we doing how
much longer and so I asked her this
question and she's 13 years old and I
and I ask her what's the you know what's
the secret to getting out of debt and
she said fortitude
good and I I thought I had to share that
touchdown all right lane and Kaylee and
the team 57
000 paid off in 26 months make it 105 to
135 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Music]
wow it's incredible that's amazing how
impressive very nice this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality best-selling author is my
co-host today open phone to Triple eight
eight two five five two two five draylen
is with us in Columbus Ohio hey Dryland
what's up
hey guys thank yeah better than we
deserve sir how can we help
so basically
um I'm finally in a position now where I
can Faith I've been living in paychecks
to paycheck since I graduated um two
years ago
um but the fact that I can say now I
have a car loan that is driving me crazy
um my car loan I have ten thousand nine
hundred dollars less for this Carlo and
it's a 16 interest rate and I know
that's pretty high but the reason I I
the reason I accepted it is because I
didn't have any American Credit at the
time right so I figured after a year I
can refinance this but because I'm
Canadian by the way I know that might
have sounded a little bit weird but
um I I was going to refinance it but I
got approved for it based on my credit
but my employment history isn't long
enough so I just feel like I'm stuck
what's your income
um so right now I will be around forty
thousand dollars okay and you're working
40 hours
um no I'm now I'm pushing it to around
50 hours a week
for forty thousand dollars
yeah
um so I just started um in home
renovation and I'm in a labor so I'm a
pretty low position I'm working my way
up okay
but you're paid by the hour
15. yeah you're paid so much an hour so
if you work more you get more money
yeah exactly okay great all right can
you get any more hours
yeah I can get a little bit more hours
but
um at the moment I just made a
partnership I'm about to launch a
landscaping company as well so I'm going
to have more income coming in through
that okay good
okay and how old are you
I'm 27. okay
well here's what I would do
if I were in your shoes I would say 16
percent
every morning
me being charged 16 interest pisses me
off
yeah and I stay mad all day
[Music]
you said this is driving you crazy it
drives me crazy on your behalf yeah I'm
just I'm just hearing it I'm going crazy
so if that's the case then I could
pretend I could make a pretend thing in
my head and say gosh if I don't pay off
ten thousand dollars in four months I'm
gonna like uh die of a disease or
something I mean you know just I mean
what if you had to find ten thousand
dollars in four months to stay alive
you would find ten thousand dollars in
four months you would work like 100
hundreds of hours thousands of hours you
would not worry about anything except
getting ten thousand dollars right yeah
that's what I want you to do
okay you wouldn't recommend selling the
car I would recommend paying your car
off in four months
because all you do is work
and you don't have to worry you're not
gonna die from hard work right before
you die you'll pass out
you're going to be fine you're gonna be
fine because here's the thing uh the
good news is you did something really
stupid you did it at 27 so you have the
whole rest of your life to never do that
one again
[ __ ] okay and that's the way I look at
me losing everything when I was 28 and
bankrupting I I you know there's a whole
bunch of stupid stuff I did in that
story that I spent the rest of my life
not doing and consequently have been
able to become very wealthy after that
uh because if you can just not repeat
the stupid stuff that is an
accomplishment for most people in four
months yeah I like the idea David just
of putting a 16 in like a marker on your
on your mirror every morning yeah and
just like because what you're going to
work like an absolute animal yeah I mean
you're going to go for but you can do
anything for four months that's gonna do
27. you know you're there for four
months it's not four years it's not 40
years I don't want you to be a
workaholic I don't want you to be out of
balance with your life I don't want you
to lose Jesus and your kids and your
family I'm not talking about I'm talking
about four months pay your car off yeah
and then you reverse this ridiculous
mistake because the car is not
ridiculous now if you told me you owe 30
000 on the car and you made 40 I'd be
going dude sell the car that's just nuts
but it's not that expensive a car as a
percentage of 40. it's just this glaring
what idiot idiot idiot right it just
reminds you every morning that reminds
me of my stupidity it's like I get an
email every morning you're stupid you
know I hate stuff like that and it just
it would drive me bananas and so yeah
that's how that's all I want you to do
let this become a healthy righteous
anger
that causes you to drive through this
four months and clean this mess up and
that's how I would do it if I can't work
up in your shoes Kyle is with us Kyle's
in Amarillo hi Kyle how are you
hi I'm good
good how can we help
so my question was how does okay so like
how does a spender learn how to get in
the habit of saving just because I I
love to spend I have a habit of just
spending and spending and spending and
I'm since now that I'm 19 I got to get
in the habit of saving while I'm young
instead of keeping that habit of
spending spending spending
okay well I'm a spender too so I can
relate to that are you a spinner saver
you're a spender I'm a spender you're a
spender yeah Sheila's a saver yeah yeah
so
um there's a couple of things you need a
reason
to do it a Hawaii
and right right now you don't really
have a reason other than this feels like
it's wrong but uh when I went broke and
I had to learn okay I know I'm not a
natural saver but saving money seems
wise versus being broke which is kind of
what you're saying Kyle right and so how
do I do that well what I figured out was
most Spenders too by the way are
generous
are you fairly generous
yes I love being generous okay so what I
figured out is if I invest and save I
have more money to spend and more money
to be generous with
so it's like I I have a reason now to
save and to systematically save to
become wealthy because I can increase my
generosity and I can increase my
enjoyment with spending yeah and so I
can spend now and not think anything
about it versus spending and having this
like Financial hangover the next morning
wake up with a headache and go what did
I do last night practically speaking
Kyle there's been seasons in my marriage
where I literally give my debit card to
my wife because I take cash and put my
wallet so when it's gone I it is gone
you set yourself a system to protect you
from you put barriers in front of me
until uh it's like bumper Lanes at the
pool and I mean when you're uh bowling
I'm sorry not the pool when you're
bowling so that I can learn I need these
guardrails and that's me as a grown-up I
should know better with a PhD in
Psychology I've got to put some barriers
in front of me so that I can get myself
back on yeah put systems in your life
that help you
uh stay tuned to your goal right and uh
you know and so okay my goal is uh I I
want to
be a be a be a spender that's who I am
but I want to do that with it with
wisdom right and I my goal is I want to
be a saver so what do you do to what has
to be true to cause that to happen and
you know an example would be an auto
draft uh out of your checking account
directly into a mutual fund that
automatically saves for you see that's a
system that turns you into a saver
because you might not remember to do it
it's why you tell people to cut up the
credit card so you can't right chop them
up that's right the same thing works for
um your marriage right I got a few
buddies that a hundred percent of the
time they call they will I know they're
gonna ask hey man how's your marriage
how y'all doing and there it's it's
again it's a it's an accountability it's
a check-in how are things going I know
that's gonna happen every time we call
right and so it's having setting up
those systems in your life that none of
us are perfect not all of us are trying
to figure it out and but I know where I
want to go so I know I've got to have
these accountability systems in my life
I'm so much of a spender that I used to
think when you were leaving Costco or
Sam's and they check your receipt that
they were checking to see if you really
spent two hundred dollars
no you were you want to know if you won
that day
would you check see if I wanted to
scratch off the biggest one this is the
biggest one today like no Dave sorry I
gotta go but yeah if you don't spend 200
they got they point the finger back into
the bill and go go get the six gallons
there was a family of you need six
gallons of mustard everyone needs six
gallons of mustard and you're not up to
your 200 go back in there
gallons of peanut butter 55 gallon oil
drums full of peanut butter
oh this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is James Childs producer of the
Ramsay show did you know the Ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
intentional about your character you can
have money and a career you are the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsay show
where that is dumb Cassius king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice
this is an entree leadership theme hour
what that means is we're going to be
talking to business owners and Business
Leaders all across America questions
about your business how to operate IT
issues problems even the mental health
issue having to do with leadership uh
it's a bit of a strain for the last 18
months for sure leaders have been
through hell in American Business and
for that matter around the world and uh
you know if you're facing that Dr John
deloney joins me this hour and Ramsay
personality and of course a host of the
Dr John deloney show where we talk about
mental health issues and uh uh so so man
we we Dave we went to Summit which is
the Premier business leader event that
we put on right right and um by the way
the phone number here triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you've got
a question about business protect
quickly in that zone we're going to kind
of concentrate on that zone but we'll
take your questions about anything
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so yeah we go to uh entree
Leadership Summit which is the one of
the Premier leadership events in the
world it is ours but it is legitimately
top of the top of the shelf right and
the best speakers the best teachers in
the world on leadership and on business
show up there and of course I spoke
there of course you spoke there this
year it was a pretty incredible event
yeah it was really remarkable uh and a
lot of that you know is about strategy
and how to run your business and how to
use data how to hire and fire those
important business things how do you
operate this thing and then who are you
when you're running it
and
man I I took a little bit different
track and just want to talk about
man behind a business owner is just
a dad right just a guy trying to run a
business and raise his kids and be a
Community member and or I'm just just a
woman who's trying to keep her household
duct tape together and then all sudden
their Community says you're not allowed
to go to work anymore and she's got nine
employees
and I've been overwhelmed just with the
response
to
I I I'm trying to balance all this stuff
and man I'm carrying around stuff that
from when I was a kid when somebody told
me hey you're a loser you're not going
to work it's not going to work for you
and suddenly I look up and I got 17
employees well I'm a business leader now
what's that supposed to mean and how do
I manage this and manage this and manage
that and then this guy comes in and says
he's quitting and she's leaving and it's
a lot for everybody and you said it best
it's been
absolute hell and one of the things my I
got a cohort of mental health
professionals across the country that we
interact with each other we talk and
I'll call and ask them questions am I
seeing stuff right and
we were talking that 2020 was really
like taking a two liter bottle and just
shaking it up and there was two things
that were going to happen people were
going to be open that top slowly and let
that air out
are they were just gonna pop the top on
that sucker and here we are seven months
later after 2021 is kicked off and
everybody's out of gas they got nothing
left man and then we are not even done
with the year yet right yeah we're just
watching people fall apart
yeah the um
the fact that we're all human beings and
we all carry our stripes we all carry
our uh scars yeah
um as you told us talked about in that
uh talk you know every time you have
trauma it's anything little trauma is a
pebble all the way up to Major traumas
of brick in your life and if you don't
unpack your backpack and you carry all
those bricks and traumas around oh and
then by the way just go ahead and have a
20 20. right
uh and yeah people are just on their
knees even in 2018 you still got
employee nonsense I mean we still had
all that but somehow you could function
through all that but you were on your
last nickel of energy at last minute
your tank is you're using up but then
let's just go and put another weight on
it right and try to shut the whole
freaking thing down so we talk about
this on this Ramsey Show and you've
you've just done like a shape-shifter
event over the last 25 years talking to
people
with about the margin in their life
financially if you are leveraged out
that the other end of that fulcrum comes
due someday right and the same thing
works relationally and the same thing
works with your body right you got no
margin that's right it's just it's
sandpaper on sandpaper that's right man
bone on bone yeah and it uh it's just
gonna grind and and so yeah if you're a
leader
uh that is honest with yourself
including me
um that that's where it's been this year
yeah it's like um
you know I was doing pretty good leading
uh but then it put another thousand
pounds on your back and you look at this
and you go
I don't know what the hell I'm doing
yeah right and then and then oh you know
what it's and it's the craziest thing
Dave because then the voice of that
coach comes back from 20 years ago and
says I Told You So or that employee that
left 11 years ago and wrote that letter
to you you go they say and you're this
kind of person you go you are evil see
now it's proven right yeah and you start
finding proof of your own hurts
everywhere you look right and so yeah
give us a call Triple Eight two five
five two two five man we love to talk to
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five Steve is with us in Des Moines
hey Steve welcome to an entree
leadership theme hour what's up
hey thanks for taking my call
sure so
my situation is I'm a 22 year old
realtor and I've been in the business
for about a year and a half now and uh
through the start of my new career I
have been experiencing some new levels
of stress that I just haven't
experienced before and I don't know how
to deal with this stress and it's
starting to take some uh negative
physical effects on my body yeah
usually does yeah the body's a
remarkable uh
a ledger book it reminds you that you're
overdue some areas so I just started
laughing when you said you started your
business as a realtor in a year and a
half ago I'm trying to think of an
analogy that's like saying I got into
Aviation business and they put you on
the rocket to Mars as your first trip
right so how's it been man
uh you know it's a pretty brutal
business to get in
um at the time that I did uh the market
is just full of realtors in my area so
the it's pretty difficult to penetrate
but um things have really been picking
up for me at the start of quarter two of
this year but before that
um paychecks were really few and far
between what's going on with your body
when you say I'm experiencing stress my
body's starting to pay the price for me
what does that mean
um so I've uh I've been losing sleep
losing uh appetite and losing weight I
have trouble breathing at times and uh
experience some digestive issues as well
so what's that all mean I'm smiling
because I mean I I don't know about you
Dave I've been there too like what what
is your body trying to tell you my man
um
well I think I'm I think it's telling me
that I'm put in some positions that I've
never dealt with before but I'm
I I have to I feel like I just have to
fail in order to figure it out I'm
scared to fail and yeah um hey let's do
this Steve hang on and we're gonna hang
on we'll talk to you a little bit more
after this break this commercial's
bearing down on us and a great question
how to pay our bills around here because
we're debt free and all you know so this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an entree leadership theme hours we
talk about business small business and
Leadership and one of the things we're
talking about is the mental health
aspects of leadership the things that we
all deal with and we're talking with
Steve in Montana or I'm sorry in Des
Moines rather and going into the break
he was describing to us he's a new real
estate agent and the the stress
associated with that has started showing
up in his body's losing weight digestive
issues can't sleep can't sleep those
kinds of things is that a fair summary
what you told us so far Steve
yep that's correct so man what's
stressing you out what about the job is
stressing you out
yeah so I've identified about three
things
um the first one is that I have a
serious desire to move out of my parents
house but I feel like I'm not generating
enough income to make that possible
the second one is that I can't relax in
Social settings because I'm too worried
about my work and I feel that I I'm
nervous that a client's gonna call me
and I'm not present at the dinner table
or with a friend and lastly I um I'm
still learning everything that uh it is
to be of the best realtor I can be but
I've incurred a lot of failures recently
and I'm I replay those failures in my
head a lot how old are you taking them
very personally 22.
when you say you've experienced a lot of
failures what do you mean
um
well I think I probably blow it out of
proportion and and I uh
I make it more than what it is but I
guess like I think I said the wrong
thing in front of a client and now they
don't trust me or I uh said the wrong
thing and now they're not going to be
they're not going to want to work with
me anymore and
um so I've had that happen before but I
think I'm blowing it up a little bit
yeah no you probably did it yeah you
screwed up but it's not it's not the end
of time right yeah you're not gonna die
from it but I mean I got my real estate
license when I was turned 18. and I can
tell you some serious butt stories of
some of the stupid crap I said and lost
deals but during the time I was 18 and
the time I was 24. or Steve the first
time I did radio was on this show and uh
you want to know about saying the wrong
thing and feeling the radiant heat from
Dave Ramsey next year oh I'm just
kidding it was it was it was a love he
you bless your little heart
so hey Steve here's the thing
um you're you are in 100 fight or flight
and when you do that your brain has one
detective mechanism where's the threat
and it begins to identify everything as
a threat
and you can't sit down you can't sit
still you can't enjoy anything and then
your body won't let you sleep because
that's time that somebody could be
sneaking up on you it just starts to
loop on you real real quick right so a
couple of things you identified here
you're not making enough money man right
you're running and running and running
and you're not making enough money and
then when you finally get around
somebody you overdo it because you're so
tightly wound up and the one thing
that's going to help you be well and
whole which is hanging out with friends
and laughing and putting the business
down you're not letting yourself do yeah
it's like it's like you you couldn't get
a date couldn't get a date you finally
got one and you were so excited you
screwed the date up right
and then when you're surrounded by
potential future dates you're just
staring at your phone hoping other dates
call and you miss the whole thing right
so uh I agree let me there's two things
pop into my head and you see if this
matches what you're saying John one is
um
there's a reality to your situation
you are 22 years old and you live with
your parents and you're trying to
convince someone to do a real estate
deal
okay neither one of those things are
evil being living with your parents or
being 22 years old or being 22 years old
living your parents any one of those
three possible mixes are not evil my
point is that if if you're competing
with someone who's uh
got exactly the same knowledge and
experience in real estate that you have
but they're 52
You're Gonna Lose
because the guy's gonna I don't mean
this mean or anything but the guy behind
the house is going to look and go I'm
not going with a kid
I'm going with the old dog and uh that's
assuming everything's equal
now if you're better you can whip the 52
year old's butt and get the deal right
but you got to be better to do that but
you have you are starting because you're
young in a uh very expensive commodity
business you're starting at a deficit
you are you are you're starting with an
uphill climb that's a reality and that's
okay I told you I got my license when I
turned 18. and uh and I sucked and I
still made some sales in spite of that
and I worked my way all the way through
college selling real estate selling
residential real estate so when I was
your age I was still selling real estate
um and coming out of college so I'm not
saying you can't do it but having been
there I mean it's hard for you to
imagine me being 22 but I mean just
Magnum PI big mustache disco suit
because it was the only suit I had and
so John Travolta meets Magnum p i sells
real estate at 19 years old knocking on
your front door to list your house I
mean and yet I still talk some people
into it that's right so it can it be
done yes it can be done but it it from
personal experience it's a climb now
that's thing one then thing two is the
reason I get in that situation loads of
anxiety is everything I turned I become
a drama queen I turn everything into
life or death because my I don't have
good perspective because I think that
one deal oh God I messed up that one
thing and I turn it into a big mountain
instead of a molehill and if you pan
back and you go in the scope of life
this next 18 months is probably not
going to Define me yeah and that that
allows you to chill a little bit so but
I'm with John if you were making 300 000
a year you wouldn't have called us
right exactly right so this is a stress
brought on by not making not succeeding
enough to make an income you probably
need a secondary career to get some
money coming in yeah and that's that's
one of the cornerstones man when you
someone is completely frazzled out like
you and man I've been there I've been
there is you got to be real honest with
yourself and so it's a it's a great
state right yeah right listen I I I
think you're a whole lot better than you
keep telling yourself you are but you
are also in an uphill climb right that's
a reality for a season right that's a
fact yeah so hey a couple quick things
take care of your body make sure you're
exercising eating right man and sleeping
do what you got to do if you're hanging
out with your friends turn off your
stinking phone lose a text message if
you're going to spend a couple hours
with folks and I know it sounds crazy
you got to get in like Dave said get a
mentor get somebody who's been doing
this for a while that will go to coffee
you can buy them coffee and it's just
going to give you some perspective and
the final thing here
talk to yourself kindly be graceful with
yourself man the last thing Steve needs
is Steve beating up Steve Peter is an
Olympia Washington hi Peter welcome to
an entree leadership theme hour how can
we help
hey thanks for having me on the show I
appreciate that a lot sure
hey Dave uh I have a question here I run
a a small medium-sized company I started
this company on 18 years old
um now uh seven years later
um we're we're running we're going
strong I you know I ran into you about
them a year ago uh but thankfully I
never did have any uh any debt with my
business so
that so to speak right I use a credit I
use credit cards for my employees
um
but you know of course I pay the balance
off every every month
um and I'm not so concerned about the
credit card points because what are they
buying what you expect
Material supplies at different vendors
uh Home Depot supplies
um you know
you know we so I mean so what's your
question
I run my business for my employees
without
giving them credit cards mine have debit
cards
but what about just pulling out of your
your checking account you know well
that's what it does if you're going to
pay it off at the end of the month
anyway you have the money right
yeah they would have them no you would I
mean if you're gonna pay off the credit
card that your employee is using at the
end of the month that means you already
have the money right
correct then just use a debit card and
let it come out of your checking account
because you've already got the money
yeah but what about the security side of
it you know employees go let's just say
they go off and play for some dumb
reason again if they go off and do that
with a credit card it's your credit card
you're liable even if they ripped you
off
the credit card company doesn't go oh
your employees charge something they
shouldn't have charged we won't hold
that against you you still have to pay
the freaking bill and if you've got
somebody don't you know you're not gonna
trust yeah if you've got somebody you
don't trust to run a credit card they
don't need to be carrying a debit card
if they don't trust them carry a debit
card they don't even run a credit card
they shouldn't be working exact same
thing
exact same thing
debit card has the same fraud protection
than a credit card has
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's an entree leadership theme hour
this day this hour Dr John deloney is my
co-host as we talk business owners
Business Leaders from across America
with all kinds of questions about their
business certainly the mental health
aspect of leadership is in play today
because we have the doctor in the house
if you're a business owner you know
problems and issues pop up all the time
sometimes there's an easy solution but a
lot of times you don't have the answer
and if you have all the answers that
means you don't have the answer
that should be a t-shirt man that was
deep maybe you've got an employee who
isn't uh working out maybe your top
client decided not to renew maybe you're
struggling to find the right person to
hire uh maybe you're burned up
maybe the grinds are getting you uh I
get it running a business is hard
leadership's even harder but you don't
have to do it alone that's why we
created the entree leadership advisory
groups when you join you'll get a coach
and a group of like-minded business
owners to help you navigate the
challenges of running a business stop
doing business alone we are meant for
Community Dr D says that all the time
and get answers that you need to lead
with confidence get plugged into an
entree leadership Advisory Group to
apply for a group text the phrase get
advice one word no spaces get advice to
4422 text get advice
to four four two two two Allison is in
Phoenix hey Allison welcome to an entree
leadership theme hour what's up in your
world
sure what's up
and my husband and I we are blessed with
the opportunity to Summit okay you're
breaking you're breaking up you're gonna
have to get where your phone's working
let's try one more time
Allison
yeah all right I'll come back to her uh
let's go to Lee and uh Leah in Cleveland
Ohio hi Leah what's up
you you too what's up
line kind of go through all of every
make sure everything's really profitable
so a year later we're kind of
experiencing this like really crazy
period of growth where we're growing and
we're trying to catch up with hiring and
putting processes in place my question
is as a business leader that was already
kind of exhausted before covid and then
covet happened I feel like it's hard for
me to kind of enjoy our success we're in
right now because I am just mentally and
physically absolutely exhausted all the
time and it seems like the seasons kind
of even if they change from you're
stressed out about not having money
until stressed out about not having
enough people like it's just this
constant cycle of exhaustion and I guess
I'm just looking for like tips on kind
of how to keep the perseverance going
that's a great question Dave I've got
some
and
academic answers to that you experienced
this stop in I'll follow
um
I think a couple of things happen when
you have an explosion of growth two
things number one think of this as your
harvest season for whatever reason the
last five years not for whatever reason
I know why last five years y'all set
yourself up in a position to be
successful the Integrity of your
business the Excellence in your work all
those reputation things led to this
moment when there was some sort of
Crisis and it paid off so in many ways
your your Fields grew a lot more you
planted and all of a sudden you got you
know two plants per seed right and right
so there's a there's a part of this
where this isn't the moment to celebrate
success this is the moment to get out
there and work the fields as hard as you
can right
um I always think of exhaustion
differently than fatigue fatigue tired
is physical
exhaustion is often philosophical it's
existential it's that why and what I
find with business owners and small
business owners and even big business
owners is
you go from a business of six of us and
we are ragtag and this is who we are and
we're scraping by and everybody's
pulling their weight and then all of a
sudden you look up and there's 15 of you
and you're getting a little more of a
machine going and then you have to ask
yourself hey is this what I want this is
cool it's everything we thought but it's
just a different company now and so you
got to stop and acknowledge it and you
may have to put new systems in place you
may have to ask yourself a hard question
do we want to keep taking more clients
is this as big as we want to be or if
not we're gonna have to get some wisdom
like you know Dave just just read that
we have to get some some coaching and
help us level up but it becomes a
philosophical question is this what we
want to be doing because this is
different than what we were even though
we're still Plumbing still serving
customers still doing that we're doing
it more of a corporate level we're doing
it a little bit bigger we're doing it
across the board we're busier we're
later we're missing games now do we want
this new life right and at some point
you got to stop the flow go go on a
retreat go with your top leadership team
go with your husband whatever that looks
like and say
whoo we used to be and now we are
let's talk about that and there's just
something about taking a breath and
acknowledging it and the word I always
use is grief and sometimes we think
grief is what you do when somebody dies
or somebody gets fired sometimes you
just have to grieve the fact that we
used to be a small Nimble the gang of
seven of us and now we're a corporation
of 50 or a team of 100 and it's just
different you grieve it it's just
acknowledging that what was is no more
and now we're going to lean into what is
and then you got to go do what the new
thing is Right does that make sense
it does yeah and I think that's where
it's like the pressure of we're not
fighting for our lives anymore in a
sense but it's like is this what we want
and I think that it's like perfectly
States it and it's good but then you
feel bad about feeling bad about it no
let me tell you where exhaustion comes
from
in this case because I've been there
like eight different times over 30 years
uh it comes from the businesses running
you instead of you're running it
yeah who owns this
yeah that's a question who owns it you
I do yeah you and your husband you own
it
then freaking tell it what to do
yeah it's not telling you what to do
anymore
you got to tell it what to do
you got to tell your business to
freaking behave you you're killing me
here
this is like a misbehaving kid you're
wearing me out
I was putting up grand babies to bed the
other night and they were jumping around
and I'm like girls y'all gonna have to
go to bed girls y'all don't have to go
to bed girls are gonna have to go to bed
and one of them says uh Papa Dave's
getting frustrated and when my mama gets
frustrated it's not good
amen you know and that that's what it is
isn't it it's the same thing this
business is jumping around on the bed
and you told it six times to bathe and
and you told her what to do and now
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to manhandle this business woman handle
this business and uh wrestle it to the
ground and make it do what you want it
to do you own it you grew it it was
grown for you it's for your benefit and
the benefit of your customers and so
around here that translates like uh when
I quit liking when I quit enjoying doing
something we do here because I do so
much of it I get exhausted at it it's
something I formerly like doing but we
just wore Dave out with it I finally
look up and go uh you stupid fool you
own the business just look at these
people and say I'm not doing that
anymore and so I stopped doing things I
don't like doing and so they all pray I
continue to like the thing that they're
working on right well but then there's
people like me who benefit from that
right yeah you better hope I love your
podcast that's right
but you know it's all it's got we're
joking around but that's when I get
exhausted when the stupid thing starts
running me instead of me running it and
I just have to throw my shoulders back
and go nip nope nope nope nope
so what's what's something means you're
going to raise your prices and lower
your volume I can run a bunch of your
customers off by double your in prices
and suddenly you'll be peaceful and
profitable yeah and I think that's where
this like it's a little scarcity mindset
of like oh if we raise our prices we
won't have as many customers yeah but
you reach a point that I'd rather do
that than feel like I feel right now
right
and uh I'm I'm okay if you know and
actually there's probably about 10 of
those customers are taking about 90 of
your time anyway because they're
freaking high maintenance
anytime I just read your mail okay
anytime you think the words but I have
to go let me respond to this or they
need me to
stop and check in with your husband and
say this is what we want to be doing
yeah right yeah it's just you need to
run this business it's running you I
think I think a step away
smack it on the bottom tell it to behave
yeah
this
that was like a paddling I was gonna say
I said talk to your husband and you said
reach over and paddle it I was just
gonna let that hang there for a minute
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
17 blessed is the nation whose God is
the Lord the people he chose for his
inheritance Benjamin Franklin said where
Liberty dwells there is my country
so here's the deal we have for those of
you on entree leadership fans out there
we have a free Facebook group for you to
join if you want to and you can bounce
some ideas around there and uh the name
of it is entree leadership tribe entree
leadership tribe on Facebook and so it's
a free Facebook group that is uh unique
to the entree leadership group and you
can get in there and bounce ideas around
and uh then that'll lead you into one of
the advisory groups probably as well and
uh that that's the next step after that
a little more formal than just to being
in a Facebook group bouncing ideas
around but we're going to be there to
help you either way so check it out free
Facebook group entree leadership tribe
private Facebook just for you folks that
are doing business out there and want to
share in our discussions on that
Allison's in Phoenix I think we got her
phone straightened out what's up Allison
hi so um my my husband and I we were
able to go to Summit about a month ago
which was amazing and we came back with
so many things that we wanted to add to
our business and we've made a lot of
changes
um but the problem is I'm still having a
hard time separating work and home just
because our situation is a little unique
what makes it unique
um so I I started my business a year ago
in March of 2020 which probably the
worst time congratulations maybe ever
yeah yeah I think yeah yeah your timing
sucks
yeah two weeks before the lockdown yeah
oh my God
so I I didn't think it was going all
that well until a couple months ago and
it's really started to pick up
um to the point that I'm I'm passing it
off to my husband and I actually have
another
um startup that I want to put all my
time and energy to
um but I'm training my husband and
passing it all off to him
um and I'm still running okay so what is
the unique situation and what's the
problem
um just that I am working throughout the
day we're both working at home and we
have basically three businesses
um that we're running all out of our
house and so we work during the day and
then come home and work during the night
um which we're totally fine doing for a
while but at a certain point we want to
have a normal life have kids all that
um and it just is taking over our life
yeah this is a it's one of those things
that you say how do you lose weight and
you say diet and exercise it's simple
but there's a trillion dollar industry
right this is a very simple boundaries
issue and it's going to be very complex
for you to untangle it it's going to
take a lot of discipline and a couple of
months of learning and practicing how to
do this
um I'll to give him credit man I just
shoot his own horn but Dave and his
families is a family business they work
together and I've seen them in meetings
and then I've seen them hanging out at
the house they do it better than anybody
I've ever seen but this is about
boundaries he's is when you and your
husband get very specific about when we
are working and when we are being
romantic when we are trying to solve
business issues and then we take that
hat off and then we get into building
our marriage and relationships otherwise
I'm telling you right now I've seen it
it will drown your your relationship
completely pull you underwater and you
won't be able to get back up
do you have a physical uh office in the
house
uh no we we have a one bedroom apartment
so the whole place is kind of the office
and the everything okay
um then you got to flip that around
yeah meaning you've got to have your
Romantics you gotta make proximity space
you got to go somewhere you need to take
one corner of the living room and set a
desk over there and or two discs facing
each other over there and then the other
corner has a television or whatever and
you don't have your your business
paperwork spread over the coffee table
in front of the couch in front of the
television and on the kitchen table
while you're trying to eat you need some
physical boundaries uh because that'll
cue your mind oh I just stepped out of
the office oh I just stepped into the
office and then you all you set each
other up accountable and you say we're
going to work late on Tuesday night and
Thursday night and Monday night is off
limits and Wednesday night we go on date
night and the only time we violate that
is if we uh uh Book on a really
lucrative appointment or something
across one of those and then we switch a
night meaning that that night we were
going to work late becomes the date
night and so you just set yourself up on
a a rigid schedule to reprogram your
brain and try to create some physical
space to do that as well because you've
got to have some visual cues and one of
the visual cues is a clock telling you
what time it is it's time to stop it's
time to change from business executive
to wife change from marketing executive
to husband uh it's time to change from
production to not working and being at
home and that for sure means that any
business screens like email and so forth
aside screens will screw up your evening
more faster than anything else well and
they'll violate those boundaries
and it may be something as simple as
somebody calls the workday over and
y'all go take a 20-minute Walk Alone to
read directions yeah you come back to
the house and now we're married we're
not co-workers that's our drive home we
went for a walk and now now listen to a
podcast and now that I'm home yeah that
I'm home I'm dad now that I'm home I'm
husband I'm wife
um now that I'm home I'm not the other
thing and that's what John's talking
about that our family has worked so hard
on because when we work together all day
long on something we love yeah with
people we love uh stopping is very hard
and really it's like you know is there
such a thing as too much ice cream no
actually but work skills right being
really good at my job here sometimes
makes those skills don't work when I'm
trying to be a dad they're different
skill sets right yeah it's a different
sword yeah yeah you need to take your
sword off when you get home put it above
the mantle yeah put take your boxing
gloves off right yeah and uh the one you
use at work doesn't work on your family
that's right and so take it off and just
old-fashioned sewed above the mantle you
know put to put the musket we've been
out hunting Bear all day let's put the
musket above the mantle right and uh you
don't you don't turn that on your
three-year-old that's exactly you know
it's a different set of tools and um so
yeah that's that's a beautiful question
Allison I love where you are the
beautiful thing is is that you've got
the things working
um you you
two of you in a one bedroom apartment
starting yet another business bothers me
it sounds like you like maybe you should
focus a little bit instead of being
spread so thin but that's a different
question and a different answer so it
might play into this because you might
be trying to do too much with too little
uh there's only so many hours in the day
as they say and uh but that that's a way
of looking at this so one of the things
we did with um I recommended
folks who were homeschooling their kids
who were getting those boundaries was
something as simple as
put a hat on when you're a teacher and
when Mommy or Daddy's wearing the Hat
they are Mr so-and-so or they are
teacher and then that hats off then
we're Mommy right then we're daddy again
and he gives those kids a a physical cue
yeah like oh I can go hug and be silly
versus I gotta get that assignment done
right yeah I don't have to take my uh my
mom seriously but I better take my teeth
seriously that's right that kind of
thing uh mama let me get away with this
but the teacher never would okay but
it's a visual cue I mean even
all the way back to when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth and I was in college
they um you know they said set your desk
aside in an area inside the you're
living you know where you're going to
live the the home you're living in set a
desk aside and don't do anything at that
desk except study
so when you sit down at that desk your
brain says okay time to study and the
same goes for your bedroom right yeah
don't don't do work in bed don't
um don't re you know
watch crazy movies like the bed is for
just a couple things man and not for
work and other things because it just
it's all about the physical spread your
receivables all over the bed that's a
bad idea that's right it's not it's just
you get it you just yeah you're exactly
right there's something about our minds
that is that simple and it's helpful to
just give us track give ourselves tracks
to running intentionalities the key
there good show John Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality my co-host today that
puts this hour this entree leadership
theme hour in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the Ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsayshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to Nashville
and tell Dave your story
[Music]